and now I'd like to introduce Cameron  Diaz is going to give out the first  award you know I was just thinking that  if you took Cameron Diaz Jennifer Lopez  and Halle Berry and put them all in one  room I forgot what I was saying there is  Cameron Diaz  it is my honor to present the first  Oscar of the evening once upon a time  parents took their children to see  animated features today's animation has  reached such a level of sophistication  but the children take their parents here  are the nominees for the best animated  feature film that delighted audiences  both young and old ice age Chris wedge  lilo and Stitch Chris Sanders spirit  stallion of the Cimarron Jeffrey  Katzenberg spirited away hai-yah  Miyazaki Treasure Planet Ron Clements  and the Oscar goes to see spirited away  I am music  the Academy congratulate kayo Miyazaki  and accepts this on his behalf  thank you so much